[Music]
time now for a final exam where we pick
contestants who follow the news against
one another to see who's been paying the
closest attention we've got a double
special edition of final exams later two
pretenders this evening have married
each other not tonight but years ago
Rachel Campos Duffy is regular here on
Fox her husband is a member of Congress
from Wisconsin congressman Sean Duffy
and hopefully this will strengthen
rather than divide their union it's
great to see you thank you you're
breaking new ground here I'm excited to
be part of that okay we're excited too
okay now you know the rules but I'm
gonna repeat them for the sake of people
watching at home I'm gonna ask the
questions the first contestant to buzz
gets to answer the question you must
wait until I finish asking it in order
to answer you can answer one say
acknowledge by saying your name each
correct answer is worth one point if you
get it wrong we detract a point the
cruel math of final exam best of five
wins all right are you ready I'm ready
all right is there any way I win this
Tucker winning doesn't you know actually
gets you a victory that's another show
okay according to the rules laid out for
the national game show Commission all of
today's questions must be either about
food or animals we went with food so the
first question is this is multiple
choice please listen carefully President
Trump says he doesn't care what
lawmakers call the border wall and
ordered a food offered a food-related
suggestion which name did he suggest was
it a quarter pounder with cheese B
pancakes C peaches I think it goes by
definition - your husband
I'm sorry the judge the judges have
waited on this I'm gonna go with C
peaches you're gonna go with C is it
peaches whatever you wanna call it's
okay with me they can name it whatever
they can name it peaches peaches peaches
peaches you both know that I did and I
thought the question was you know you
knew it too well I think she has to wait
for it we're all multiple choice have to
be back
do you have to wait till we finish
asking question okay okay let's see we
can do it this time I know
Costco the store says it is sold out of
a 27 tub of food that is a shelf life of
20 years what type of food was it oh
that was not running I hit it first it
was macaroni and cheese I think you have
to hold it down oh okay I hit it first
was macaroni and cheese is it macaroni
and cheese
everybody loves macaroni and cheese but
now you can get 27 need to invest in
that I'm getting one myself kind of a
remember your official position of
prepping is doll that's crazy
question 3 another multiple choice okay
a world record was set this week for the
most liked Instagram photo ever the
picture doesn't feature a famous person
or in exotic places already nearly 50
million likes it's a plain boring
photograph of what a a banana be a lemon
see an egg congressman I'm gonna go with
Kylie Jenner I believe and see an egg
then she tweet the egg out I have no
ideas check it out but I'm not a member
of Congress is it see the end world
record egg an account with that very
name posted this single photo it's a
picture of an egg the egg currently has
26 million likes how did that counting
I'm saying either you live in this
country or whole life and you still
don't understand it what is that right
there must be like an egg commission
that promotes eggs
[Laughter]
question for one last multiple-choice
hey I'm winning the right as to why I'm
not good it's not for me to keep score
our viewers are watching chaos hit
Flagstaff Arizona on Monday when a
tanker truck flipped over spilling 3,500
gallons of which liquid all over the
highway was it a chocolate B coffee C
beer Rachel beer was it C beer 3,500
gallons that's how much liquid chocolate
spilled in Arizona interstate a
chocolate River they described it for me
[Music]
doubled down and I you know I admire
that she's from Wisconsin so of course
she's not being liquid all right final
question the Clemson Tigers invited to
the White House for a candlelit feast to
celebrate the recent victory over
Alabama what type of food did the
president serve the team congressman I
was there this morning
McDonald's from the McDonald's that the
food came from I was there this morning
was it McDonald's we have peaches we
have 300 hamburgers many many prints
fries or all of our favorite foods I
want to see what's here when we leave
because I don't think it's gonna be much
and Carlos owns the store and it wasn't
and I just want to say it wasn't
exclusively we're hearing from our
judges
but macaws was represented and you're
right
you sort of win because McDonough was
McDonald's Wendy's and what was the last
one I was gonna say faster Burger King
no it was it was an ecumenical Carlos
owns the McDonald's that gave the food
to the White House Congress he's gonna
shut down he's out
I've been hungry again it's a shared
victory it's really a victory for your
family we're pro-family on the show so
I'm an award in fact our Eric wimple
commemorative mug to you Rachel
Thank You Tucker that was great
congratulations to you both I wouldn't
watch the episode that you had with him
on it's great you two back there really
what I feeling sad sometimes I pull it
up and smile or if you're on a shutdown
exactly that's right it's amazing it's
like a name alright that's it for this
week's final exam pay attention to the
news all week come back Thursday to see
if you can beat the expert